ce serait ma chute à chaque fois c'est
même plus pratique et moins
impossible de me faire ça je sais pas
bien c'est beaucoup trop précis je le
préviens mon ami je vais pas comme ça
les jeux sont légaux des aléas des
danseuses adore repos
cette boutique ou sur internet
je suis son réalisateur
[Musique]
ok
[Rires]
[Musique]
il est comme ça
[Applaudissements]
milliard le yacht d'ennahda qui danse
nue sur le ponton elles seront là
[Musique]
j'ai vu la demande de l'inde un peu
paumé lannoy la connaissent pas les voir
comme ça qu'est bon elles étaient plus
de sous dans le micro
[Musique]
ah oui quand elle chante we did you know
i'm poteau et bien dans les bacs mais
c'est bien ça l'est moins
à l'essai est obligé de films et où il
se rend ce mardi nestlé et vous surpris
mais je sais pas moi qui tiens c'est
bien comme ça viergela du beurre du port
un aventurier mais du carlton comme
terrain c'était parlant des cadeaux
[Musique]
et